[Music]
welcome to pine grove
welcome to pine grove welcome to pine
grove
is somebody gonna say that every 12
seconds
if you ever need anything only gonna be
here a month during the renovation
can i help you this table is by
invitation only are you serious
she used to say serious as a heart
attack but then marjorie killed over so
she don't say it anymore
we call them the queen bees guess what
the b stands for
saving seats clicks they're like mean
girls but with
medical alert bracelets let's go
remember sweat is just fat crying for
attention
looking good ladies and gents are you
flirting with me
yes i'm interested in joining the bridge
club
someone needs a hearing aid the roster's
full okay
well i heard janna pointing dexter
surreal
this isn't high school it's worse high
school we graduate
here we die ah come on be one of us
we are the cool ones i've never thought
of myself as cool you're not
with us you will be
[Music]
give me the purse what purse my purse i
want you to take your wrinkly ass back
inside
we're the queen bees we don't take crap
from anyone
i must tell you the other night i looked
up but there you were and then you
started to dance
it was magical has that line worked for
you in the past
let's go crazy
word on the wheelchair ramps that you
and dan are
nice it's ridiculous if it works out
great
if it doesn't at least you're riding the
bike again
then this metaphor dan is the bike
yes he is i'm gonna need a helmet
we have got to live every day you want
to get baked
[Music]
should we sleep together oh don't look
so worried
that kind of experience is not on my
bucket list
you